there is a fascinating new poll from unh  the university of new hampshire they ask  who is your first choice for the  democratic 2024 presidential candidate  the first place candidate is not joe  biden it's pete but a judge at 17  certainly within the margin of error joe  biden is in second place at 16  and after that it's elizabeth warren and  gavin newsom at 10 and then people in  the single digits this is fascinating i  have been saying two things for a while  number one i don't believe joe biden is  going to run for re-election in 2024.  number two i think pete buddha judge and  gavin newsom are two very strong  candidates and along with elizabeth  warren who i previously said is a  relatively strong candidate who is  brutally attacked  on the regular um buddha judge and gavin  newsom are polling well despite uh not  having announced uh any candidacies same  with elizabeth warren so i do think all  of the signs point to a non-abiding  nominee in 2024 for the democrats